Kizer Khan became an advocate for gold
star families after his very passionate
speech at the 2016 Democratic National
Convention he challenged then
presidential nominee Donald Trump stance
on Muslim immigration now he is critical
of president Trump's phone call to the
wife of the soldier killed in share this
morning for the very first time the
widow confirmed that mr. Trump told her
that her husband quote knew what he
signed up for mr. Trump as you know has
denied that Khan is a father of army
captain who Mayan Khan who was killed in
Iraq by a suicide bomber in 2004 captain
Kahn saved the lives of his fellow
soldiers and posthumously earned both
the Bronze Star and the Purple Heart
Khan is telling his family's story in a
new book it is called an American family
a memoir of hope and sacrifice he shares
his journey from growing up as a son of
a Pakistani farmer to fulfilling his
dream of studying at Harvard Law School
Khan writes about the struggles to raise
a family in America we welcome Khizar
Khan to studio 57 welcome sir thank you
thank you very much when you saw all of
this attention to the president's call
what did you think I was disheartened I
was shocked to words came to mind I wish
somebody would advise him dignity most
dignity for these families for my force
brave sons that were protecting United
States under most difficult
circumstances privacy and dignity
restrained he was not advised of those
sentiments of those words yet I thought
I heard General Kelly say in the
briefing room that he said there's
nothing you can say that will comfort a
family in this loss even general Kelly's
own experience saying hearing it
sometimes from a fellow surge soldier
was more important do you think that
that the president wasn't advised not to
make these calls and it might be better
to write a letter his advisers know his
habits and his nature
they must have insisted put those words
on piece of paper and
placed it in front of him to read it
from there so there is no
misunderstanding that was not done but
when you heard when you heard John
Kelly's context of what Donald Trump was
trying to say do you think that Donald
Trump was deliberately trying to be
insensitive when John Kelly put it in
perspective
it seemed that Donald Trump's delivery
fell short of what he was trying to say
did that matter to you yes it does
because it is not the intention of who
is saying what is being said this is
from the president of United States most
accurate words most accurate sentences
should be uttered depending how those
are received not how those are said and
that was not sure the president call or
should they simply send a letter because
you can't call everybody or they don't
call everybody that is a very personal
decision that ought to be left to the
leader of this country what he decides
that is his prerogative but utmost
respect dignity and privacy be granted
to these most respectful families the
bravest families of this nation you talk
about your book American family that
this was a very difficult book for you
to write it was a book you never
intended you describe yourself as an
American patriot not because you were
born in this country but because you
were not born in the country before I
apologize for taking just one sentence I
wish to pay a tribute to you three
through you three to the press of this
country the fourth pillar of democracy
the world looks up to the press of the
United States for example
thank you for your service to this
nation your continued bravery under
these very difficult times now we can
talk about the book that was not the
intention but under these very difficult
time divisive times children were
reaching out to me knowing that I
practice law
will we be thrown out elementary school
children can we finish our school before
we are thrown out of here
I would harden them I would take the
Constitution out of my pocket that I had
keeping since 2005 we tell all that the
story in detail in the book how that
letter came that card came to us mr.
Khan you said that you hadn't really
even intended to speak at the Democratic
convention in fact all your family and
friends said don't do it don't do it
don't get us involved in this it was
only because you got a letter that day
that made you change your mind what did
that letter say from middle school for
middle school children that I had spoken
in different gatherings birthday parties
and other places wrote us a card for
names name of their middle school it
said mr. mrs. Khan would you make sure
that Maria is not thrown out of this
country we love her she's our friend I
read it twice and I tell that story in
the book in detail took it to rosada she
showed it to her without saying a word
she said how is your wife my wife she
said we will go we should speak when we
have so this is a book about your life
is called an American family memoir of
hope and sacrifice what is it you want
us to understand about your journey and
your family's journey from Pakistan to
Harvard Law School to living in
Charlottesville Virginia it is the
goodness of this country the values that
must be remembered under these most
difficult times of our nation divisive
times there is so much good in this
country I have spoken
262 communities in the last 15 months
each and every member had been hopeful
firm believer in the goodness of this
country and its value so I remind in the
book how we personally our symbol of the
goodness of those countries we are the
beneficiaries of the values of
discouraged son believed in the goodness
of this country we have to say something
about your son it was his day off that
day mr. Khan when he was killed and you
tell a very compelling story about how a
car drove in and he goes out with his
hands up the universal sign of surrender
but in ten steps his life he lost his
life and you're still thinking what did
he
in those 10 steps kale that speaks to
the goodness of this country he was made
in here we brought him two years old he
was raised here he learned everything
from here that is what makes this
country great
it teaches ordinary citizens to be
patriot when the time comes they stand
up for the sake of others protecting
others and he did that he was a symbol
of well you believe those dials will
keep us strong they certainly will I
have seen those values and the values
and the belief in those values of
America through our destination this is
strongest than ever before the more
difficult time we face the more those
values shine and make us beacon of hope
for rest of the world we tell though the
stories of traveling of falling in love
with the dignities and the freedoms that
destination I really clearly remember
entering the courthouse to take the oath
of citizenship I had lived under to
martial laws no rights no liberties but
then I walked out as a citizen I looked
at the sky without any dignities I
walked in I came out with that piece of
paper to most people that is piece of
paper to me it meant so very much that I
became person of equal dignity and then
sitting in the DMV all of us and know
what a difficult experience that is I
saw I saw the rule of law in work
everybody was treated with equal dignity
or in dignity whatever you wish to call
it everybody waited everybody waited
even you came out and had a good DMV
story that's rare to do you raised a
wonderful son we thank you so much
joining us today at the two important of
mine not only to do children serve but
their families serve too so thank you
for your service your family services
thank you an American family is on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
book